Let's go to our caller from the seven six
zero area code.
Who's calling today from seven six zero?
Seven, six zero.
Maybe your muted.
All right, and last opportunity, four seven
six zero.
Hello.
Yes, that's you.
Hi.
Hi, David.
So I won.
Yeah.
Can you hear me all right?
Yes, I can.
OK, I want to ask you what your opinion was
on the if you heard Minneapolis' recently,
are nine of the three council members announced
that they would disband the police department
or something like that or would vote on it.
What's your opinion on that?
I'm not sure if you did in the past, but I've
not done a segment.
I haven't seen the exact proposal.
Sometimes these proposals take the shape of
essentially separating the police department
into different units or elements for lack
of a better term.
I'm not exactly sure what it is that will
actually be be made a reality if such a reality
takes place in Minneapolis.
But I'm very interested in seeing what it
is that that they come up with.
And, you know, there are other places that
sometimes are asserted to have disbanded the
police.
But really what they've done is they've kind
of separated out some of the infrastructure.
It's not not truly been disbanded.
And what that might sound like, like police
haven't been abolished, but responsibility
and super supervisory authority has been rearranged
and moved around.
So I'm interested to see what Minneapolis'
comes up with.
Mm hmm.
Yeah.
Was that a.
OK.
All right.
Seems like that cholera.
That caller went Bye-Bye.
Let's go to our caller from the seven one
eight area code.
Who's calling today from seven one eight?
Hey, Greg from New York.
First time caller.
Hey, Greg, what's up?
I'm glad you called yourself a left libertarian.
I think on some level, you know, I'm sort
of more on the libertarian side the more skeptical
of the government institutions, including
police.
And I just wanted to say a lot of the progressive
hosts are sort of coming around to the conversation
that libertarians have been having.
Okay, let me stop you right there, Greg, though,
because I need to issue a huge disclaimer
when I say I'm a left libertarian.
Mean, I'm saying small l libertarian.
Right.
So if we imagine a spectrum of authoritarianism
and libertarianism, these these are lowercase
I.
My instinct is I want to be more on the libertarian
side unless there's a compelling reason to
regulate or to involve government.
So I am not at all like not at all a capital
L Libertarian.
I just mean that on issues of authoritarianism
versus libertarianism, I tend to lean towards
the liberal a low little L libertarianism
unless there's a compelling reason not to.
Right.
I think I'm the same way, OK?
I just wanted to push you a little bit on
with my skepticism of the government.
Sure.
Right.
So, for example, just in the last few months,
we've had everyone from the W8 show to the
CDC surgeon general, including Foushee and
including Pence saying don't wear masks.
And I believe that that was a mistake that
led to the lockdown, which were supposed to
be a last resort.
The economic damage done from that and people
out of work now contributed to these giant
protests, which, of course, the police.
You know, this has been going on for years
with the Ferguson protests.
And then we had the Baltimore.
This has been going on.
You know, I'm very skeptical of having these
authorities tell us don't wear masks.
And then later saying, yeah, you should wear
masks.
And just yesterday, WHL retracted what they
said, which was that o asymptomatic people
don't you don't spread the virus.
But then they kind of walked it back with
you.
Yeah, no.
Why are we listening as regular people who
are living in the world?
Why don't we take things into our own hands,
put things that put things into the lobbies
of buildings and sell it on a private level.
OK.
So there's a couple of different things going
on here that are interesting.
First of all, you're rightly pointing out
that there have been misunderstandings about
the virus.
Those misunderstandings are not inherent to
government agencies necessarily.
In other words, lots of people.
You also had, you know, people that had nothing
to do with government saying we weren't going
to have any cases by the end of April.
They had nothing to do with government.
They were also very, very wrong.
So that part of you.
Do you agree with that, that there were there
were all sorts of things that were incorrect
about the coronavirus from industry, from
private citizens, from government agencies,
from health organizations.
A lot of people got a lot of things wrong.
You agree?
Oh, absolutely.
Many people get things wrong.
But when you centralize the decision making
in the hands of a few people that are wrong.
That's when it gets really bad.
Well, my argument would be that it's a contradiction
that you are, on the one hand, asserting your
skepticism of government power while at the
same time saying most of the mistakes were
not doing enough.
So a lot of libertarians, if presented with
the mandate from government very early for
everybody to wear masks, would have said,
I don't want that.
That's too much power.
The government can't tell me to wear a mask.
So I want you to think about that contradiction.
You're saying you're skeptical of government
authority, but you're saying they weren't
strict enough.
But wouldn't you have been saying who are
they to tell me to wear a mask if they had
said that right away?
Well, to be clear, I think there will be governments
anyway, whether it's a neighborhood or a city
or okay.
But that wasn't my question.
But that was my question, Greg.
Right.
Well, to answer your question directly, I'm
saying that because we're accustomed to listening
to certain authorities, word authority would
imply that they have the authority and the
knowledge of it.
Also, the fact that we're complet accustomed
to this versus, let's say in science or the
English language and so on.
I think that that we have to be very careful
with the messaging that's coming out from
W. They were wrong.
And that's important, too.
How are you going to put it.
They'll say so.
It doesn't happen next time.
Well so so I agree with you.
We have to.
This was a disaster on all levels.
We have to have a better, you know, more more
well functioning system.
The pandemic response team never should have
been abandoned.
The pandemic response playbook that was left
behind for Trump should have been followed.
But remember, we Trump didn't listen to the
WHL on a lot of stuff.
So at least in the United States, you said
you're in New York.
A lot of what went wrong here doesn't really
have as much to do with the United with with
the W8 show.
We have a government here that was led by
an incompetent buffoon.
So I don't want to put the focus too much
on the W8 show, even though I agree with your
critiques.
Greg.
Last thing I just wanted to say, look, I live
in New York and just look at the sense of
proportion.
The NYPD is the seventh largest arming the
world by a number of people, yet operate across
several continents with the war on terror
and expanded budget.
Why not?
When I say defined right people, I think that's
the wrong word.
Many people say you don't disinvest or reduce
the budget.
The budget of the DOJ that cannot account
for seven trillion dollars.
I mean, at what point do we finally say, look,
conservatives, we agree with you.
Let's start cutting and we will start with
the Ogie and the police force and give the
hospitals give to schools.
Why not?
Yeah, I think one thing that has been very
much missing from this entire discussion is
we talk about defunding and demilitarizing
the police.
What about defunding and demilitarizing the
military, which is very rarely being discussed
right now?
And, you know, you there is much more of a
debate as to what police departments are doing
for us than what 50 bases in Germany are doing
for us.
And I would like I agree with you, Greg.
I would like to see that be a bigger part
of the discussion.
Thank you.
All right.
I want to end with a word of kudos.
You know, there's a lot of people that don't
embrace allies, you know, across libertarians
or conservatives.
And you, David, I think, are out to talk about
the truth and stick to actually facts.
And I think there's a lot of hope that everybody
did that.
I think we could find a lot of common ground.
All right, Greg, thank you very much.
Appreciate the phone call and the kind words
that's going to do it for calls today.
Sorry I wasn't able to get to everybody, but
I do appreciate so many people wanting to
call in.
We'll take a quick break and be back right
after this.